[Music]
fans of the fast and furious franchise
will no doubt be very familiar with the
ongoing feud between vin diesel and
dwayne johnson the rock entered the
series in fast five as luke hobbs a dss
bounty hunter tasked with tracking down
diesel's character dominic toretto and
his allies
i don't have friends
i got family hobbes and dom go from
enemies to frenemies by the end of the
movie and johnson would go on to appear
in three more films in the main
franchise but things apparently weren't
always rosy behind the scenes while the
eighth film was shooting in 2016 johnson
took to his instagram to spill the tea
regarding some previous onset drama the
actor praised his female co-stars but
mentioned the men were in his words a
different story while johnson didn't
specifically name the acting partners
who caused him problems it was clear
enough that diesel was the issue johnson
wrote some conduct themselves as
stand-up men and true professionals
while others don't the ones that don't
are too chicken to do anything about it
anyway since then the two actors feud
has been a non-stop back and forth
johnson was the last to mention it
during an interview with thr in july in
which he wished the franchise well and
confirmed he wouldn't appear in any more
fast films i'll see you soon
all right you won however it seems like
diesel is bringing up their rivalry yet
again albeit in a totally surprising way
in an instagram post shared on november
7th diesel offered the olive branch of
all olive branches to his former co-star
he wrote my little brother dwayne the
time has come the world awaits the
finale of fast 10 as you know my
children refer to you as uncle dwayne in
my house there's not a holiday that goes
by that they and you don't send
well-wishes but the time has come legacy
awaits of course not only is fast 10 on
its way but so is fast 11 with both
films serving as a two-part epic finale
for the long-running series referring to
the late paul walker diesel continued i
told you years ago that i was going to
fulfill my promise to pablo i swore that
we would reach and manifest the best
fast in the finale that is 10. i say
this out of love but you must show up
ops can't be played by no other i hope
that you rise to the occasion and
fulfill your destiny so it looks like
diesel is happy to let bygones be
bygones for the sake of the fast
franchise but will johnson feel the same
way well right now johnson has yet to
respond to his former co-star's plea for
reconciliation but considering how
active he is on social media you can
probably expect to hear something soon
it's worth noting that even before his
new instagram post diesel appeared to be
over their feud in a june interview with
men's health the actor claimed his
issues with johnson came from pushing
his co-star to the limit to get the best
performance he said that took a lot of
work we had to get there and sometimes
at that time i could give a lot of tough
love not fellaini asked but i would do
anything i'd have to do in order to get
performances in anything i'm producing
nevertheless it's probably going to take
a lot more than an instagram plea to get
dwayne johnson signed on to fast 10 and
11 and there's no way to know if vin
diesel has reached out to johnson in
private or whether the social media
strategy is currently his only plan of
action unsurprisingly if the fast and
the furious fandom had anything to say
about it johnson would have signed on
the dotted line right away diesel's
instagram post was liked well over a
half a million times and had ten
thousand comments just a mere two hours
after it was posted in the past fans
seem to have taken johnson's side in the
feud but for the sake of fast 10 it
looks like everyone is on the side of
family check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies and tv
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]